if you could [ __ ] anyone you wanted and
they'd die immediately after
who would you pick that's such an
interesting question you know who I
think is really hot like um I can't
think of the name but you guys would
definitely know if you guys know sports
but I like I find like those emotionally
unavailable like um Angry coaches that
are kind of pacing on the sideline
really attractive there's a lot of them
the the you know the football players
are too obvious you know what I mean
like I don't want to be in that long
line you know but the kind of the coach
is always like a little pissed off just
like looks stressed you know even when
his team's doing well you're like this
guy never really has a real moment of
Happiness
um and there's like a few of them that I
actually find kind of attractive um but
I don't know their names do you like
what you want to play like Bill
Belichick yeah like Bill Belichick yeah
and then because I feel like he can't be
that nice of a guy you know I'm not
saying I want to kill him but I'm like
if one were to die maybe you know
him rather than um
I love it I find them very attractive
like when they're just like staring at
clipboard like a little kind of tense
about something